we are getting numerous calls and emails
about questions with the vaccine
distribution specifically for older
adults
we did get some answers today if you are
over the age of 70 you can now begin the
process
joe mohler joins us live outside cashman
center a location that will become a
mega distribution center joe that'll
start as soon as tomorrow is that
correct
yes cashman center here will be a mega
vaccination site it'll begin with public
safety workers in a pilot program now
this is part of a
larger vaccination effort right now they
are still doing testing at this location
but moving forward
they hope to do at least 2 000 vaccines
a day here
so far 29 000 vaccines have been
administered to medical frontline
workers here in southern nevada
people 70 and older can start making
appointments for the vaccine
starting now the health district and
county officials hope to get 40 to 45
000 done each week depending on
availability moving forward
now you must have an appointment to get
it it is a similar process as making an
appointment for a coven 19 test
times are limited but they are opening
hoping to open up more times in the
coming weeks
all of this is super important that
everybody realize the importance of
having an appointment because once you
open that file you have to give
the vaccines because we do not want to
waste any so it's important that people
know
if you take the time to make an
appointment please show up
there are a number of vaccine locations
including cashman center they hope to
have the site
up and running by the end of the week
for the public now the health district
also expects to transform the las vegas
convention center into yet another mega
site
as well in the future similar to the one
here now soon some pharmacies will be
vaccinating as well the state is working
on that plan and information is set to
be
possibly released within the next few
weeks now as more vaccines
and more times become available they
hope to greatly increase how many people
are given this vaccine a day reporting
live here at cashman center joe mohler 8
news now